[Music]
these singers call themselves brothers
of peace they perform in the Lutheran
Church of keturah a suburb of the
Namibian capital of India the parish was
founded by German missionaries in the
nineteenth century later in the
apartheid era cata Torah would become
notorious as the dumping ground of
forced removals to make way for white
suburbs immediacy try to adapt into that
into that context of heavy load from
missionary work and they have been
trying also to to critic to critic and
especially in the in the area of the
origins they have tried to critic and
come up with their own understanding of
who God is the understanding of the
grace in their own context even
salvation in their own context
[Music]
the Theological College where professor
own demo a that teaches was also founded
by German missionaries the Paolina Maz
it's called prepares men and women for
ministry in the Namibian Church demo
Aida is a progressive theologian this
term he is offering a course entitled
the destruction of the environment by
commercial greed 500 years after Martin
Luther nailed his famous theses to the
door of the villain burg castle Church
professor under Miranda is demanding an
eco Reformation he argues that we are
over taxing the environment in our
insatiable greed for profit he views
this capitalist obsession as the most
crucial issue for Christians in Africa
he's also opposed to a literal
interpretation of the Bible we have many
who are still thinking in terms of the
colonial theology
because they are not critical that we
have we have many congregants and
congregation members who are not
creating critical reading their Bible
critical but at our theological level
it's different where we we think that
even the Bible itself has this intrinsic
imperialistic feature in itself where it
can be racist where it can be understood
as also imperialistic and so on and we
would that's what we do at the logical
level Luther's African airs like
professor and I'm aware de are
developing an assertive African theology
but there is also a white Lutheran
community in Namibia with a strong
attachment to its German identity its
landmark church is the Christus cassia
in downtown VIN Turk in the early 1880s
a German merchant called Adolf lüderitz
landed on the southwest shores of Africa
he traded with the nomadic people he
encountered here and persuaded them to
give him land the German Kaiser
eventually appropriated that land
proclaiming it a so-called German
Protectorate
German missionaries had already ventured
into the territory from South Africa
they established a mission station near
present-day Vinh Turk in 1844 and called
it barmen after the town in Germany
where the Rhenish missionary society was
based
[Music]
Yussef at Chennai explains this history
to his three sons on their annual
pilgrimage to oka hunty please meet
Donohue Kohana he tells them about
missionaries with foreign sounding names
like Kleinschmidt and who Gohan in
August each year
Josefa Chennai and his sons hike Taraka
hanja 60 kilometers north of Indyk to
attend a gathering of their people the
Herero experience of German settlers
soldiers and missionaries is a complex
often painful story the Berlin
Conference of 1884 to 1885 also known as
the Congo conference was a land grab it
divided Africa among the rival European
powers Imperial Germany won the
territory that became known as German
Southwest Africa present-day namibia
from then on colonial officials in
Berlin like power wobbuff saw to it the
German settlers and traders could
conduct their business in Africa without
interference
Josefa chennai tells his sons how the
germans stole their ancestors cattle and
then they gave him a bit of money he
says and a lot of liquor the
missionaries told their converts they
must obey the german kaiser he was a
Lutheran like them they said and God had
appointed him their ruler it although no
man tomorrow nobody knows it was Eddie
German businessmen were eager to get
their hands on the country's rich
mineral resources gold copper and
diamonds the mining companies divided up
the territory among themselves the
Kaiser sent a contingent of several
hundred troops to German Southwest
Africa the purpose of this so-called
protection force was to guarantee the
safety of the German settlers traders
and miners but also the missionaries
traces that the German presence are
still visible all over Namibia
the Germans built the railway for
economic and military purposes
the landmark christos Cheshire now
stands in the shadow of the grandiose
National Museum of Namibia the museum
used to be housed in the old fort the
headquarters of the former Protection
Force
here you can see a once famous
equestrian monument the rider of the
southwest now relegated to a back
courtyard the Lutheran Church in Namibia
is still struggling to come to terms
with its colonial heritage unfortunately
our brothers and sisters from Germany
created two churches one white white
white Lutheran and one black we are now
struggling with those with those
divisions which were not our own making
yeah they were made somewhere else and
we big we have they have become our
problem now integration is still a
challenge for Namibian society in the
schools as well as in churches
the local Lutheran churches have a lot
of political clout almost 90% of the
population is Christian and about half
of those are Lutheran this workshop is
taking place in a Christian guest house
in Bend Hook young people from Namibia
Botswana and Germany all from Lutheran
parishes are rehearsing a musical the
songs and script portray the various
issues they each deal with in their
lives it's called live my life
[Music]
these are the great-grandchildren of
those early missionaries and of the
Africans who used to be called mission
children the other kids are focusing on
the problems of everyday life in the
other two African countries problems we
don't really know about when you first
hear about them you think oh but it's
part of their everyday life so they're
tackling them it's also their focus when
we say just describe your life in Africa
if you could change it what would we see
if potion good advice Moodle and star
4:14 this is life in a former Township
lunch at a fast food restaurant is
considered a luxury here a hundred years
after Germany lost its colonies visitors
from Europe still encounter poverty I
totally reject the idea that we Germans
still carry a burden of guilt because
I'm 20 it has nothing to do with me but
I'm wondering if we'll be confronted
with that
and whether they are grudges I'm
wondering but I really hope it's not the
case if fingers band about how severe of
me we are referring to the
reconciliation between the Germans in
the header after the 1904 genocide that
was done so the
the group wants to talk about the
conciliation Joseph Anton I a relates
this particularly brutal chapter in the
history of Germany's involvement with
Namibia to his sons in the colony known
as German Southwest Africa tensions
boiled over towards the end of the 19th
century the Germans behaved towards the
natives increasingly like white
supremacists and were supported by the
church Monsieur Nava happened the
missionaries thought they had turned the
Herero who they converted to
Christianity into loyal subjects of the
Kaiser st. Paul says we must obey the
authorities that have power over us in
this case the Kaiser and his deputies
that was what the missionaries preached
to the Herrera myth you nodded in here
with an operating table the colonial
administrator at the turn of the century
was tired or Lloyd vine with military
toughness he tried to force an agreement
on the Herero and others the nama and
damara Germany would continue to draw
the major profits from the mines but the
native peoples would receive a small
percentage the missionaries supported
Lloyd fine
[Music]
however the Herero were led at this time
by an intelligent and assertive chief
called Samwell Maher arrow at first he
tried to cooperate with the German
authorities even wore a German uniform
and the typical hat of the protection
force but Maher arrow soon realized that
the colonialists were exploiting his
people they bought cattle from the
Herero for a song and then demanded land
to graze them land that belonged to his
people Samwell Maher arrow appealed to
the missionaries for justice they
responded by accusing him of rebelling
against his Kaiser at all the Germans
came and told the Herero they had to
become Christians they built a church in
oka Hanyu they also established a school
and taught the Herero to read in any of
you worry local data ok good boy Rambo I
hear it okay that was good for Mechanica
but then the German started to impress
the Herero we saw that they were not
honest first they said become Christians
and then they attacked us
in January 1904 rumors began to spread
that the Herero were gathering in large
numbers angry and armed most of the
colonists sought refuge in the
protection force Garrison's but the
trader Adolf Diekmann procrastinated he
was caught by the rebels and shot dead
in oka Handia together with his wife and
six-month-old baby
this incident sparked outrage among the
white colonists with the killing of the
demons the conflict escalated into war
the local Lutheran missionary algas deal
viewed Samwell Maher arrow as a friend
he spoke Herrero fluently and on several
occasions had acted as an intermediary
between the paramount chief and Governor
Lloyd fine but the incident in oka
Handia turned deal against his Herrero
friend he accused the chief of being
responsible for the murders in a letter
to the governor he raised the
possibility of war and said Samwell
Maher arrow must accept his fate from
the hands of God he deal would do
nothing to help him
terr door Lloyd vine tried to contain
the conflict he thought some limited
punitive action by the Protection Force
would be sufficient to put down the
revolt and placate the colonists but the
Kaiser took a different view wilhelm ii
considered lloyd vine ineffective
within a few weeks thousands of
reinforcements from Berlin were
dispatched to the rebellious colony
Lloyd vine was replaced as governor
leftenant general lo Tov on torta who
had already earned himself an infamous
reputation as the butcher of East Africa
was put in charge and given command of
military operations then the horror
began the missionaries called our people
to the church and said let us pray then
as the people prayed German soldiers
came and fired into the church and
killed many people that may be just a
legend but there's no doubt that font
Otto's methods were brutal the Herero
were nomadic herdsmen the german general
trained artillery on their camps the
Protection Force was ratcheted up to
more than 8,000 men the opposing force
was no more than five or six thousand
lightly armed herdsmen our ancestors
tried to resist the Germans but they
only had rifles and sticks they fought
but they weren't armed like the Germans
however the Herero had one significant
advantage they knew the land using
guerrilla tactics they managed to kill
some 200 German soldiers in the first
three months of the war
[Music]
then general font otter made his
notorious decisive move with artillery
and machine guns he drove the Herero
onto a strip of land at the foot of the
varta burg mountain 40,000 of them men
women and children then the Germans
attacked on three sides the only hope
for the Herero was to flee across the
arid or mihika plateau those who try to
emerge from the desert were shot by
German patrols along the perimeter of
the Omaha ger thousands of Herrero died
of hunger and dehydration it was the
first planned genocide of the 20th
century obviously through the order of
General von Trotta that every man woman
and child must be killed
and those who want to survive must flee
the land and so the end result was that
80% of what people were actually you
know massacred they were killed
[Music]
by the end of 1904 more than 60,000
Herrero had been murdered fewer than
20,000 survived and they were only
spared because a group of Christian
missionaries demanded an end to the
killing the survivors were interned in
concentration camps that was the
official designation of the prisons
where they were held virtually as slaves
[Music]
the genocide that was committed over a
hundred and eleven years ago has left
some very deep scars emotionally
psychologically physically and alloys
only overhead of people the we were
deprived of our means of livelihood the
land which is the very basis of our
livelihood our cattle in the hundreds of
thousands were confiscated
we were very means of livelihood were
taken away at the end of their three-day
journey
Josefa Chaney and his sons have arrived
in oka Handia for the annual gathering
known as Herrero day the event
commemorates the Herero Chiefs and in
particular Samwell Maher arrow who
resisted the German occupation achieve
greets them with the traditional
blessing
the commemoration lasts three days the
men wear military-style fantasy uniforms
in the German manner as they say and the
women wear the traditional dress of the
Herero it's an occasion of national
pride but also overshadowed by colonial
history our people until today feel this
effects of total poverty and deprivation
we have lost our ancestral lands we live
in poverty and this affects our with us
on a daily basis the suffering of the
Namibian people didn't end with the
collapse of the colonial power at the
conclusion of the first world war the
League of Nations transferred the
so-called South West African
Protectorate to South Africa the
government in Pretoria stretched the
tentacles of apartheid over its Western
neighbor
it wasn't until 1990 that Namibia
achieved independence
that independence was preceded by a long
war of attrition with alleged atrocities
on both sides
on a hill outside Vint Hoch stands a
memorial to the country's freedom
fighters this is also where Samwell
Maher arrow is now buried the Herero
leader who defied the Germans pastor
Laurence trouser chika is showing heroes
acre to this international group of
Christians he explains that the monument
is intended to honor all of Namibia's
heroes those who like Samwell ma Herrera
resisted the German colonial force and
those who fought against the forces of
apartheid they are all Namibian heroes
also the the fallen heroes Cuba and the
Soviet Union supported the liberation
struggle and Namibia's heroes acre is
very much in the communist style
there's no commemoration of the German
settlers here
history has labeled them oppressors
Feroze acre in Windsor is a place where
my heroes that fought the liberation
struggle are buried so I feel very proud
when I'm here yes and I feel very good
that that now Namibia is a better place
for living for for all of us that are
living in Namibia so for me personally
it's I'm very proud of this place
actually yeah how'd you save it Namibia
is one of the main beneficiaries of
German development aid but the Herero
also want reparation for the suffering
inflicted on their people in the
genocide perpetrated by German troops in
1904 we expect that just like Germany
has done with other people in similar
circumstances our people are also
equally entitled to reparations to
affect social justice to what has
happened they're not in a symbolic way
but in a meaningful way because that's
the only way that we can heal the wounds
of the past and affect actually create
the basis for meaningful reconciliation
between our two peoples and our two
countries Russia in cata Torah this
former township is hardly any different
from other suburbs of in Turk it has
supermarkets tarmacked roads and masses
of cars but one aspect hasn't changed
since the apartheid era no White's live
in cata Torah the Lutheran Macedonian
Church is an entirely black parish
[Music]
the music group comprising singers from
Namibia Botswana and Germany is
performing in the church this evening
they've been rehearsing together for a
week and found a common rhythm
[Applause]
[Music]
the young Germans will return home with
the impression that black Namibians
don't feel any animosity towards Germans
in spite of their colonial history from
Namibia they traveled to Berlin where
this year the 500th anniversary of the
Reformation is being celebrated at the
Evangelical Church convention
[Music]
[Applause]
here prominent Lutheran's are discussing
whether the Reformation benefited
distant countries like those in Africa
and whether the church today bears a
responsibility for the mistakes of the
past the Evangelical Church in Germany
has explicitly acknowledged its guilt
with regard to the genocide in the midea
now it must bear fruit
it must have political consequences
Germany has to do some more work on this
issue but I don't have a bad conscience
about the fact that Lutheran's and other
Protestants brought the gospel to
southern Africa the question of
reparation payments specifically for the
genocide committed more than a hundred
years ago will no doubt occupy the
politicians for a long time but earlier
this year the German Lutheran Church
officially admitted that its
missionaries in South West Africa didn't
do enough to oppose the war of
extermination in the former colony
further it acknowledged that many
churchmen were imperialistic and racist
and the Lutheran's in Namibia have
accepted this apology in a step towards
reconciliation
[Music]
you